alors bernard
donc je sais que ça faisait un petit peu
ça faisait un petit peu attristé ce qui
vous est arrivé c'est le dernier jour
sur les réseaux tout âge je sais que oui
j'étais sûr plus encore aujourd'hui mais
si vous voulez je défends mon amitié
avec avec harry c'est un ami je lui
resterait fidèle mais ce que je défends
surtout c'est la présomption d'innocence
évidemment sur sert d'abord comment on
condamne les gens on ne sait pas moi
j'ai jamais dit que je savais et on ne
sait pas personne ne sait on a vu tous
les grands dit dans les journaux on ne
sait pas donc c'est ça que je défends
c'est la présomption d'innocence et là
mais maintenant on me met carrément
bernard montiel hashtag culture du viol
s'il ya un paquet de tarés h et la
culture de l'amitié
je sais que ça touche et vous demandez
encore parler de talent évidemment que
c'est toujours parce que en plus il ya
quelques artistes qui me me rentrer
dedans qu'ils rentrent dans la meute je
suis un peu charrié certaines artistes
ah oui ah bah oui alors alors il ya un
truc sommes hallucinantes qu'on m'a
ressorti je vais quand même le dire
ces années 80 quand je présentais la une
est à vous j'ai reçu la maman de izia
higelin et quand une femme absolument
ravissante vous allez voir ce qui s'est
passé exactement
c'est sur les vidéos donc c'est facile à
retrouver jeudi à cette jeune femme
ravissante jeudi excusez moi je suis
troublé vous êtes très belle et vous
avez un beau décolleté point
culture du viol c'était déjà un gros
lourdaud et c est alors hashtag et les
gens qui ont suivi derrière choqué c'est
des gens que j'aime bien barbara prat
vie je le dis juliette armanet que
j'adore qui est une grande artiste qui
qui met du baume ils le faisaient les
mots je sais je suis choqué d'où ça sort
parce que tu dis à quelqu'un qu'elle est
belle ça c'est une vieille vidéo en plus
des années 80 bien sûr nous cherchons
mort tu vois c'est incroyable la
définition de l'eau potable a changé
donc l'eau qu'on pouvait boire en 1982
est devenue invivable aujourd'hui c'est
tout mais il se trouve quand même que
dans ses mouvements et des choses très
positives c'est aussi pour ça que des
gros plans avec plus dé main au cul et
donc la génération mais ces exagérations
font partie des évolutions dans un
temporaire mans on a besoin de ces
exagérations sinon la société n'évoluera
jamais mais bien sûr il ya des victimes
collatérales et bien sûr mais j'ai même
pas envie vous savez aussi que je
travaille avec la fondation des femmes
qui luttent quand même contre les
violences faites aux femmes depuis des
années je suis obligé de tellement je
reçois des mots mais d' insulte grave tu
n'es pas content admettons je parle pas
des habitants admettons que tu es un ami
qui est réellement violé quelqu'un il te
contamine pas par son action je ne
fumais pas contaminer par l'action de
quelqu'un
sur mayotte et je pas piéger du tout
bien armé la question jens et la
présomption d'innocence est
effectivement sans qu'on n'a pas la
preuve que ton amer fait quelque chose
tu arrêtes ton ami mais même en revanche
là où moi je te rejoins tout petit peu
moins fleuri j'apprends qu'en revanche
mon ami c'est lui je crois et mon ami
est un self made man violé les normes la
selo je te rejoins pas jamais peut-être
détourner mon ami bernard conte eux
conservera son amitié pour arrêt si les
fesses et ainsi construire je les 10
heures j'ai dit que je lui ai donné mon
amitié c'est un ami et c'est pour ça que
j'ai dit je ne veux pas y croire je ne
veux pas en revanche si je suis trahi
qu'effectivement il a commis ça c'est
sûr que c'est autre chose alors que
j'avais donné l'exemple d'alain delon
avec eux de manière inconditionnelle il
faut défendre son ami sauf s'il ya
trahison sa fille rétroactivement doute
aperçu qu'il avait fait un acte qui
trahit d'amitié qui trahit la confiance
c'est ça
alors non parce qu'il est chaud il ya
des choses qui me semble moins grave que
d'autres accords que le cas d'un viol
c'est un absolu non le cas de mes
dessins pour moi n'était pas un bien
un vol est un vol mais commence un
travail de reconstruction on peut rester
à ses côtés pour l'aider il ne pense
qu'il a failli ternir est le travail de
reconstruction
et coûteux yann moix à chaque fois parce
qu'il a beaucoup voilà il a énormément
de brio et talent mais moi effectivement
c'était il ya une petite ambiguïté non
il n'a pas à dire là j'ai trouvé et
mathieu a trouvé et valérie à trouver
des cabines petit ange et lever cette
ambiguïté il ya des choses qui sont
imprescriptibles effectivement absolue
mon ami je découvre que c'est un
pédocriminels ou si c'est un violeur
récidiviste
effectivement j'ai du mal et je me dis
moi même que j'ai été trahi croient ils
ont vu douanes va détourner ça veut dire
que ça n'a jamais été un ami parce qu'il
n'en a jamais parlé donc il y aura déjà
remis dans les chambres à coucher des
deux c'est non seulement mois six mois
au chili c'est avant tout le temps ça
peut littéraire comme dans les ouvrages
en car il a dit non mais il a raison on
absolument tout dit aussi j'ai un ami
mais mon meilleur ami s'il est une chose
qui me semble qu'on consacre
répréhensible à rabat il ya quelques
quelques tabous levée de phily le bio le
terrain c'est impossible pour moi de
regarder comme ami après le défendre
avant de savoir évidemment qu'il faut
défendre son ami à tout prix évidemment
évidemment tant qu'on ne sait pas après
c'est quand il ya les preuves et les
faits ça ne me sentais tellement bafoués
c'est incroyable c'est choquant merci en
tout cas par yann moix merci
désorientation d'être venu nous voir on
va reparler encore dans un instant de
saint céré qui a énormément de réactions
là dessus